behind me is samsung's transparent LCD
it's one an innovation and design
engineering award here at CES this year
it's 46 inches 1366 by 768 resolution
and it's about nine millimeters thick
and weighs 10 pounds it's really cool
it's a TFT LCD display so you can touch
it and it reacts to your touch you
control it via HDMI and USB and it could
totally end up in our homes one day it
could be your desktop display you can
even have it on a window kind of like it
is here with the blinds you could even
use it in the boardroom kind of
displaying information from your work
about your employees about an upcoming
meeting it's really cool I love checking
out this future tech here at CES